[Musique]
deux fois champion d'europe
une fois champion du monde et deux
victoires aux 24 heures du mans en
catégorie lmp2 le team signatech est
désormais reconnue dans la sphère du
sport automobile grâce à un homme et son
équipe
enfin je dirais sa famille
alors c'est à la fois pour moi une
fierté en effet d'avoir créé ce cette
famille et que le ressenti que les gens
peuvent avoir de l'extérieur c'est qu'il
ressent vraiment qu'un esprit de famille
mais c'est aussi con assez compréhensive
on passe tuque 200 jours par an ensemble
on vit des choses passionnantes on
partage des émotions à la fois
des joies et des peines donc forcément
ça crée des liens
plus qu'un effectif quoi c'est c'est
tous des frères avc / technique
performances mécaniques mais aussi
communication marketing et recherche de
partenaires il n'y a peut-être pas à ces
deux jours dans une année pour cette
petite équipe
le lien qui permet de se surpasser c'est
donc la confiance et la passion commune
[Musique]
étant aux berrichons de naissance
ça fait très plaisir de vivre ça avec
l'équipe qu'on a actuellement est
constituée de jeunes dynamiques qui ont
tous la banane et tous envie de faire
leur métier ça mais on est entouré de
passionnés donc en général ça fait une
osmose naturel si on gagne on pleure si
on fait rien on pleure parce que un peu
plus et si on perd on perd on perd aussi
il n'y a personne d'extraordinaire ici
que des gens normaux avec une volonté de
fer qui échange qui partagent conçoivent
d'apprendre qu'ils étirent les
enseignements de les expériences vécues
et par contre qu'on une envie de gagner
des places et de montagne extraordinaire
voilà
sera mais pas deux jours car à ce niveau
de compétition les jours et les nuits
danse parfois avec une autre énergie
lambois c'est cette angoisse qui était
qu'on anticipe cette angoisse contre
cherchait à chercher le détail et le
diable dans le bétail et c'est cette
angoisse qui fait que ben on est
performant le moment une faux et ça
c'est sûr bien sûr le moteur à explosion
commence à avoir du plomb dans l aile
mais les courses de voitures resteront
et sans doute que philippe le dos doit
avoir déjà une étincelle ou une bulle
d'hydrogène en tête
[Musique]